as the presidential race heats up
there's a whole lot of noise out there
about immigration illegal immigration
illegal immigration illegal immigration
it's hard to separate fact from fiction
so here are some of the biggest
immigration myths busted Donald Trump
frame the debate with these now infamous
words they're bringing drugs they're
bringing crime they're rapists but guess
what the facts don't agree no studies
out they're actually linked violent
crime to immigrants one study even found
that immigrants are less likely to be
involved in crime than the rest of the
population the violent crime rate in the
u.s. actually went down as the number of
immigrants increased it's almost as if
people who come here are more interested
in making a better life for themselves
as for the idea of folks flocking to the
US illegally in record numbers also not
true the number of undocumented
immigrants has actually gone down from
2007 to 2012 only 12% of people living
in the US were born somewhere else and
undocumented immigrants they're only 3.5
percent of the population about half of
undocumented immigrants in the US are
from Mexico but here's the kicker net
migration between the u.s. and Mexico is
get this zero that means that there are
just as many people going to Mexico as
there are coming to the u.s. believe it
or not immigrants are not stealing your
jobs undocumented immigrants make up
only 5% of the US labor force and they
pay billions in local and state taxes so
they're funding programs like Social
Security and other benefits that they
don't necessarily get that said only 1/3
of undocumented immigrants work in the
formal economy which means the country
loses around 20 billion dollars in
payroll tax every year
Trump wants all undocumented immigrants
to go which is strange for a guy who
says he gets the economy the US economy
would lose two point six trillion
dollars over ten years if all
undocumented immigrants left and the
actual process of deporting them would
cost taxpayers two hundred and eighty
five billion dollars over five years for
that price you could hire more than a
million public high school teachers and
pay their salaries for five years and
deporting undocumented immigrants isn't
necessarily what the American public
wants two out of three Americans support
some sort of path to citizenship could
it be because they realize that the
exception of Native Americans everyone
in the u.s. originally came from
somewhere else
you